- Okay.
Before we start I asked
to brag on you because
you did something very nice.
And I don't even know
if you remember. But...
I was going to do something and
then I couldn't or whatever.
And then you sent me a message saying,
"Hey, we're just thinking
of you and praying for you."
And you were so nice, like
behind the scenes you are.
He's very kind.
- That's... Thank you, thank
you. (audience clapping)
- I wanted to lead with that.
But thank you so much for being
part of our we love LA week.
- Yes, thank you.
- So you're in the My Little
Pony next generation movie.
- Yes, yes.
- That's exciting.
(audience cheering)
So were you aware of the die hard, like,
my little pony fan base,
and it's the bronies?
- Yeah, the brony.
I was, I was aware cause my kids,
when they're like four
years old, five years old,
they had like My Little Pony,
I believe it was equestria.
It was like they had a series.
- Yeah, I've seen.
- Yeah, they have a series and my kids,
they like, they're begging my wife and I.
They would just say like
please take us to this,
to see like the first ever
animated My Little Pony movie.
- Yeah.
- And so...
This is really in many ways,
just kind of like a love letter
to my kids of yesterday and
to pay it forward because
I had so much fun just kind
of learning all about...
I, I knew about equestria.
I knew about that whole
world like years ago.
- Yeah.
- And so to be, you know,
it's a very full circle moment.
- Yeah.
- That was a main reason
why, why I did it.
And in many ways,
it's a shout out to my
kids back in the day.
(audience cheering)
- No, that's so cool.
- You were in Crazy Rich Asians.
God, I love that film so much.
- Thank you, thank you.
(audience cheering)
- And it was a big step.
It was a big step for
representations on film.
So how do you feel about
the new Marvel movies?
- Yes.
- Like Shang-Chi and the Eternals.
I'm very excited.
- Yes.
- How do you feel?
- I just saw, I saw
Shang-Chi and it is my...
- Did you?
- Yes.
- It is my favorite MCU movie of all time.
(audience clapping)
It is my favorite.
- I'm so excited.
- And you had Simu Liu on the show, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- He is amazing in this.
He is the real...
I've known him from back in the day,
even when I had like my show, Dr. Kenny,
we would just hang out.
Because he was on Kim's Convenience,
this great show in Canada.
He is the real deal.
He is a real life
superhero on an off screen.
He's going to inspire
so many Asian Americans,
because you're seeing that
representation and doing it well.
And then Awkwafina, she was my daughter in
Crazy Rich Asians.
- Yeah.
- And to me, she is
just a global treasure.
- People love her.
- So to have that and
Michelle Yeoh, Tony Leung.
It...
- It looks like action packed.
- It's action packed.
The action scenes are the best of any
Marvel movies I've ever seen.
- I'm so excited.
- And it was just proud and emotional.
Where as an Asian-American,
you're seeing this
representation on screen.
- Yeah.
- So it really is...
- It's so important.
And, and the fact that it's just good.
- Yeah.
- It's just a great, great movie.
- Yeah, but it's also a bonus, cause then
little kids that might
look like them think,
oh, I can do that.
- Exactly.
- To have that representation and
Jon Chu, who directed Crazy Rich Asians,
he said, this is more than
a movie, it's a movement
- Yeah. And I think that to me, it's,
it's not just one person
hitting it and crossing over.
It's just everyone in this community,
like pushing it forward, you
know, like basically you,
you want to lift the tide so all
of the boats can sail on it.
- Absolutely.
- So that...
- Room for everybody.
(audience cheering) - So
that's what we want to do.
Yeah, absolutely.
- That's a great...
- Yeah, yeah.